second piece of hugely positive news and
i'm not you know what before i even get
into this let me go ahead and say
because this is positive news
all over social media
people are glad about it but saying go
further and i'm going to talk about that
but
the piece of positive news that i want
to talk about now
is that the biden administration
announced on wednesday
they were going to extend
the student loan debt repayment
deadline
meaning instead of payments resuming on
february 1st they are now set to resume
on may 1st they have kicked it back 90
days
giving people more time i guess to make
adjustments whatever it is those three
months mean the world
to people suffering under the burden of
student loan debt
and this wouldn't have happened
and this is really the positive part of
the story this wouldn't have happened
without the push
from the public for the administration
to do this
that's the real positive part of this
story
that the activism worked much like
actually with the covet test yet a week
and a half ago jinsaki kind of laughed
it off during a press conference of what
are we supposed to send a test to
everybody you know give it to them for
free
and then after pushback they're like
okay we're actually we are going to do
that
same thing with this student loan
repayment
people have been pushing them warning
them even economists have been warning
them
you're about to deal a major blow to the
economy taking out roughly 85 billion
dollars from it when these payments
restart
is that where you want to be in an
election year tanking your own economy
putting hardship on your voters
and the administration says okay we're
going to kick the can down the road 90
days
so now it comes to the other part of it
right cancellation
full-blown absolute cancellation and of
course that is what a lot of people are
pushing for
to be honest that is what i'm pushing
for that is what i want to see happen in
this country
that's what needs to happen
yes i understand all the arguments on
the other side you took out the loans
you're responsible for repaying them
what do we do next we pay pay off your
house
well yeah you want to get people into
homes you want to get them off the
streets you want to give them the
opportunity for a real chance at a
better life yeah you could you should
so i am all for 100 percent
full-blown student loan debt
cancellation short of that
i'm in favor of biden keeping his
campaign promise which is to pay off ten
thousand dollars of everybody's loans
he did make that promise
it's still on his twitter you can go and
see it yourself he said he would do that
and of course we can talk about the
economic impacts of that which you know
some people that's the only thing that
matters
so i went through compiled these
statistics looked at some old uh studies
from this year earlier this year here's
what we have right now as of today we
have 1.57 trillion dollars in student
loan debt held by more than 40 million
borrowers
the livy economic institute of bard
college used data from 2016
and they found that cancellation of the
outstanding student loan debt would
translate to an increase of 86 billion
to 108 billion dollars on average per
year
to our gross domestic product here in
the united states
information from just a couple months
ago this is actually from the federal
reserve says that those
uh payments
are averaging
200 to 300 dollars per month
that's the average some people pay less
some people pay more
but that's what we're looking at so
a full cancellation
not just ten thousand although ten
thousand would cancel debt for millions
of people
you're talking about giving them an
extra two to three hundred dollars per
month which is what they've had during
the pandemic
that for a lot of people that's like an
extra paycheck
and do you know what people do
with that money
well we know
because the analysis also came out this
week along with the child tax credit
they're using it to pay off other debts
some people are actually able to put
some of it in savings
they're using it to pay medical bills
they're using it to pay housing expenses
they're using it to buy food
they're using it on car repairs
which is something that a lot of people
tend to overlook as a major factor
you know when we talk about those
studies that show that people can't
afford an emergency of seven hundred
dollars or more a lot of those
emergencies either involve in a mere an
immediate health crisis or an automobile
crisis
car repairs are not cheap
and the cost of all of those continue to
go up each and every year
and that becomes a major factor that
takes away somebody's ability to get to
and from work
to take their kids to and from school or
daycare or whatever it is
so that is a major problem so two to
three hundred dollars a month
if we had full student loan debt
forgiveness
would absolutely be life-changing for
these individuals and we have seen that
since march of 2020
when these payments were first paused
so i applaud the administration
for listening to the public and pushing
this 90 days back
personally
i want it all canceled economically
it should be all
cancelled
zero it out
change people's lives for the better
and of course the other side of that
that is certainly would certainly
help democrats politically in the
midterms
look we got to take a quick break i'm
fair and cousins sitting in for david
pakman you can find me all over social
media at fair and balanced
we'll be right back with more of the
david pakman show
the only streaming service that
specializes in documentaries is
curiosity stream and you can get
curiosity stream one of our sponsors for
just 15 bucks a year when you use my
link below this will give you access to
the world's best selection of
documentary films there's always
so many that you can't get on netflix
hulu or amazon
i just finished watching a tremendous
film the ceo of sinaloa sinaloa a region
of mexico it's about el chapo
fascinating fascinating curiosity stream
is a must-have
if you love documentaries they always
have the best and newest titles they're
always adding new things to the library
and you can watch on all of your devices
they've got documentaries on every topic
you can imagine curiosity stream is
giving my audience 25 off a subscription
making it just 15 bucks a month go to
curiositystream.com
pacman the link is down below